i say it's all hogwash it's insanity
worse what's even worse is that they're
setting up black kids to fail even more
and that's the real crime
[Music]
can you believe it i'm still here that's
right living inside this tent for 100
days from november 20th of february 28th
bringing to you the awareness that you
need to know about the violence on the
south side of chicago but also to raise
as much money as we possibly can to
build a center on this block that is
much needed called o-block it's called
o-block because it's named after a young
man named odie perry who was shot and
killed the gangs picked up the o in his
name and started calling it o block well
we decided we like the o we're going to
keep it o block but it's going to be
change to opportunity block and i want
to thank fox for giving me the
opportunity to bring to you every day
rooftop revelations where i can talk to
you about the issues
the ideas and thoughts
as it relates to the city of chicago
and around our country
one of the biggest debates in america is
how to close the achievement gap between
white and black students
personally i care far more about
educating the child than what color he
or she is
that's because a poor black child and a
poor white child have far more in common
than a poor black child and a rich black
child but
let's put that aside i will address this
black white achievement gap because it
needs to be addressed lately i've seen
some of the most insane ideas come from
the left on how to close the gap up
north just above chicago there's a town
called evaston
in their school district called district
65 only 30.6 percent of black students
met the college ready readiness
benchmark in reading
as opposed to 83.7 percent for white
students in math the gap was even wider
horrible numbers but what was even more
horrible were the proposed solutions
the district held the segregated staff
meetings they spent 100 000 on a report
that produced no direct evidence for the
racial gap instead they blamed the
tuskegee syphilis experiment
illinois sundown towns and the force
sterilization of puerto rican women
okay
that's part of our history
what exactly how
does this historical
example explain the current problems
they don't
the school also hired diversity equity
inclusion staff person
they gave money to outside racial
justice organizations to talk about
these things like white privilege
i say it's all hogwash it's insanity
worse what's even worse is that they're
setting up black kids to fail even more
and that's the real crime
that's the crime that needs to be talked
about
what will close the gap
it's simple a true and honest
and vigorous education
in this light good public charter
schools are the very way forward
we have seen them close the gap in new
york city and elsewhere
success academy and
even mosquitoes is just one example
they can
fire the bad teachers they can correct
wayward students
they are not bound by ineffective racial
injustice issues
the good charter schools are not
concerned with
meaningless optics
but with educating kids
this is not a mind-blowing situation
but i will say this
we have grown so weak as americans that
we allow this kind of racial justice
idiocy to undermine our kids education
we need to all step up and say enough is
enough
i know i have to i'm on the south side
where racism is the least of our
problems education
is one of our biggest problems and
that's why i'm fighting so hard to
educate these kids and why it's my goal
to open a charter school within project
hood community center it will happen it
must happen our kids need
to have a fighting chance
and they need to have someone
fighting for them every single day
that's the reason why i promote school
choice
i believe it's the best way go to go and
i believe it's the best way for our
children
well
just my thoughts
my opinion my viewpoint
thank you for tuning in to rooftop
revelations and as i always say
till tomorrow
peace